would you go so far as captain america
went to rekindle an old flame stay tuned
to find out what made his and other
superhero movie kisses so memorable
in the 2002 movie spider-man there are
multiple times when spider-man saves
mary jane watson from danger
but it's the second of their encounters
that made movie history
one rainy night in an alleyway mary jane
is accosted by a group of thugs
spider-man intervenes and easily
incapacitates her assailants but this
time he decides to stay for a bit
talking to mary jane as he hangs upside
down mj asks do i get to say thank you
this time
spidey stops her from removing his mask
not wanting to reveal his identity to
her so instead she opts to just pull the
mask down a little bit revealing his
mouth
peter parker puckers up and the two lock
lips as our hero hangs upside down the
scene was an instant classic becoming
one of the most iconic kisses ever not
just in superhero movies but in film
generally it's been parodied everywhere
from saturday night live to shrek 2.
midway through x2 xavier's mansion is
raided by government agents and the
x-men are forced to flee wolverine rogue
iceman and pyro decide to hide out in
iceman's childhood home which leads to
one of the most iconic moments from the
original x-men trilogy up until now
rogue's mutant power has prevented the
two from having a physical relationship
whenever she touches someone she drains
them of their life force a brief touch
can cause them to lose consciousness but
a prolonged touch can be fatal
additionally whenever she does this to a
mutant she temporarily gains their
powers
however in this moment marie and bobby
decide to risk it and they chance a
brief kiss
they do so and a moment later as rogue
is pulling away we learned that she's
temporarily gained iceman's ice control
powers in the coolest way possible
as rogue exhales her breath is visible
like she's in a 90s dentine ice
commercial and it doesn't get more
romantic than that
throughout the 2004 film hellboy one of
the major sources of conflict in the
film is the love triangle between
hellboy his pyrokinetic ex-girlfriend
liz and liz's new friend fbi agent john
myers
though the three bicker for much of the
movie in the end our heroes set aside
their differences to defeat the
villainous rasputin and save the day
however after the battle hellboy and
meyers discover that liz has been killed
hellboy kneels by her side and whispers
something a moment later liz
miraculously awakens returned to life
she asks hellboy what he said to save
her and he replies that he said hey you
on the other side let her go because for
her i'll cross over and then you'll be
sorry
liz smiles and kisses him and as she
does so her pyrokinesis activates
bathing the couple in blue fire hellboy
being a demon is unaffected seeing
hellboy reunite with his old flame is
certainly a beautiful image to end the
film on but an unintentionally funny
aspect of the scene is the fact that
myers is just stuck there the entire
time awkwardly watching his crush make
out with her ex surrounded by literal
flames that symbolize their rekindled
love ouch
although they certainly have their ups
and downs without a doubt one of our
favorite superhero couples of all time
is mr incredible and elastigirl and they
share a classic kiss towards the end of
the first film the family has just
returned to the city after surviving a
truly hellish ordeal on syndrome's
island during their time there bob
suffered a devastating emotional blow
when he believed for a time that his
family was killed by syndrome's forces
since reuniting the pars have been
working together as a near perfect
superhero team but the shadow of that
moment still hangs over bob before our
heroes confront syndrome mr incredible
tries to convince the others that they
should stay behind offering the
enigmatic explanation that he's not
strong enough at first helen starts to
criticize bob and rightfully so bob
keeping the rest of the family at arm's
reach was what caused most of their
problems in the first place bob then
clarifies his statement saying i can't
lose you again
i can't
not again
i'm not
strong enough
helen kisses him and after a few long
seconds of liplock says that if they
work together he won't have to be
no list of famous superhero movie kisses
would be complete without a mention of
1997's batman and robin which features
the deadliest kisser in all of superhero
fiction poison ivy see in addition to
her primary super power and ability to
control plants ivy also possesses the
ability to kill people with deadly
poison smooches throughout much of the
film ivy is attempting to drive a wedge
between batman and robin by seducing the
latter midway through the story it seems
as if this has worked
robin arrives in ivy's lair and climbs
into bed alongside her he asks her what
she's scheming and she agrees to tell
him in exchange for a kiss a tense
moment passes but nothing happens ivy
was clearly expecting robin to drop dead
but he hasn't
robin then peels off a set of fake
rubber lips that he was wearing over his
normal lips as protection against ivy's
toxins
it's a twist that's like everything else
in this movie extremely silly and yet
utterly delightful in its unapologetic
campiness
though the romantic relationship between
tony stark and pepper potts eventually
comes to be one of the central emotional
anchors of the marvel cinematic universe
it takes a while before the couple
actually has their first kiss it isn't
until the end of iron man 2 that tony
and pepper finally get together after
narrowly escaping a frightening series
of near-death experiences the two
regroup and catch their breath on a
nearby rooftop and in this moment the
silence between them finally breaks
pepper confesses to tony that being the
ceo of stark industries is seriously
stressing her out and she wants to quit
but the revelations don't stop there
hopped up on adrenaline and no longer
keeping secrets from one another the two
lean in and begin to kiss the shot is
truly beautiful mostly dark except for
the twinkling city lights in the
background and the under lighting on
their faces from tony's arc reactor a
moment this breathtaking was certainly
worth the wait
the guardians of the galaxy films
feature one of the best will they won't
be relationships of all time with peter
quill and gamora though the pair
eventually do kiss in later films none
are as memorable as the time they don't
actually kiss in the first film during
their escape from an interstellar prison
peter risked his life to retrieve his
walkman later the normally aloof and
violentgamora asks why this device is so
important to him peter explains that it
was a gift from his mother and that she
instilled a love of music and dancing in
him he puts his headphones on gamora's
head to show her what he means and
starts playing elvin bishops fooled
around and fell in love
unable to resist gamora starts to sway
peter takes her by the hand and leans in
for a kiss the moment their lips touch
gamora instantly reverts to her old self
raising a knife to peter's throat and
saying i know who you are peter quill
and i am not some story i'd wait here to
succumb to your
your public sorcery
it's a beautifully constructed scene
with a hilarious twist and it ends with
one of our favorite lines of dialogue in
mcu history despite faking us out this
almost kiss is still one of the most
memorable kisses ever
at the end of 2016's deadpool after the
villain has been defeated and our hero
has reunited with his lost love vanessa
there's still one more challenge that
awaits him ever since the procedure that
gave deadpool his powers but also
covered his face in burn-like scars he's
wondered whether or not vanessa would
still be able to love him once she saw
his face
because of this once deadpool finally
removes his mask we see that he's taken
some serious precautions stapled to his
face is a magazine cutout of hugh
jackman's face with the eyes removed
undeterred by wade's lame attempt at
humor vanessa removes the makeshift
disguise and looks for the first time at
wade's true face after a moment of
contemplation she tells him after a
brief adjustment period
and a bunch of drinks it's a face i'd be
happy to sit on
this is one film that truly has a happy
ending
among the many iconic images from the
original comics that the watchmen film
faithfully recreates is one of the most
memorable kisses in superhero history no
we're not talking about the
unnecessarily long and awkward love
scene between knight al and silk spectre
inside the al ship we're talking about
night owl's dream sequence that follows
it in this surreal vision knight al and
silk spectre are standing in a black
void they walk towards each other and
begin to kiss
as they do so an atomic bomb detonates
in the background
and as the massive explosion approaches
the two continue to kiss either not
knowing what's coming or not caring when
the blast wave finally hits they are
instantly skeletonized but they continue
to hold each other as the world around
them is engulfed in flame it's just as
stunning in the film as it is on the
page
going into avengers end game we weren't
sure how things were going to turn out
for our heroes but it seemed like there
was one thing we could say for certain
steve rogers had missed his one chance
at love sure cap had managed to snag a
couple of less than stellar kisses over
the course of the franchise like his
undercover fake kiss with black widow
and winter soldier and his late kiss
with sharon carter in civil war but the
love of his life peggy carter was gone
forever having died of old age however
when the team invents time travel as
part of a plan to reverse thanos's snap
death is suddenly no longer as big of an
obstacle as it once seemed and when the
heroes have finally undone the snap and
defeated thanos for good steve decides
he's earned a little me time seven
decades of it to be exact he travels
back into the past to be with peggy
carter and the last we see of them
they're dancing together at some
unspecified point in the past they lean
in their lips touch and we cut to black
the moment is brief and though we could
have stood to see a little more we get
it steve and peggy are an old-fashioned
couple and we can respect their privacy
who would have guessed that after all
the action explosions heartbreak and
death marvel's infinity saga would end
with a beautiful kiss check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
on-screen couples are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you